austin is with us in fort myers florida
hey austin how are you
pretty great how about you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
so i'm i've been i recently just got
married about a year ago
congratulations me and my wife are
trying to purchase a house
um so i'm just trying to get some good
advice um as well
okay what's your question she also has
she also has some student loan debt
and we're trying to figure out if this
is a good time to buy a home or they
offer student loans pay off the student
loan
okay so you have the money to pay off
the student loan
um i have i have money saved before i
got married to her
and she and it's i mean i know when we
got married
it's all it's all equally as one but
it's great that i had saved before we
got married
correct but now it's hers
okay it's not it's not i have money it's
we have money now you're now we
when you get married you're french we we
john's dead okay so here's the thing
unto the the old the old-fashioned
marriage vows in the book of common
prayer
say in sickness and health for richer
for poorer unto thee all my worldly
goods
i pledge you don't hear that in wedding
vows much anymore
uh it's kind of anti-prenuptial uh it's
quite the opposite it's uh if we're
gonna share life we are going to
share the money and the problems and the
good things
because you're gonna end up sharing them
all anyway you might as well just admit
it
so uh this is a good time to admit it
and it's a good exercise for her
to accept that her student loans are
paid off that she got before marriage
with money that you got before marriage
and that's a very real sign in your
relationship spiritually and financially
that you have combined your households
and then you start then you build your
emergency fund and then you save up for
a good down payment yeah don't go into a
house without an emergency fund man
because 100
chance something's going to break when
you buy it and you don't want to walk
into that house with student loan debt
and suddenly you're swimming upstream
trying to fix stuff and
make that mortgage payment let that
house be a blessing man
and there's something that snaps
in the psyche dr john that you know when
you force yourself to do an
action that reveals that there's a new
reality
yes i i it's this uh
it's a winnowing right it's this it's
it's a test moment
to where you can talk about all day long
i know this is going to be ours that can
be ours you can hear that here
i know this is ours but but i saved it
right
yeah okay well cool pay it off right
yeah and it's it's like
it's this shaky hand signing it off when
i really do it now is when it's a real
thing yeah and i
don't want to hate on anybody i get no
no he wasn't doing anything wrong
that's a normal process whether you've
been married a year whether you've been
married 10 years if
there's people married 10 years still
talking like that oh
most 30 years 40 years with separate
checking accounts you take care of these
bills i'll take care of these bills like
roommates even
that's exactly what they are they're
roommates they've never fully come
together on this deal
but when you anything where you're
changing your life you're changing a
behavior pattern
and then you have to actually do the
action yes not just discuss the theory
of the action
there's something that snaps in the old
psyche you have to step into it it calls
your bluff
and it begins to change you physically
and neurologically changes you from the
inside out and all of that austin in
your situation
is means that your marriage is already
awesome and it's about to get a little
better
yes that's what we're saying and it's
gonna be real uncomfortable
for a minute right before it gets better
there you go yeah as you write that
check you make sure
your hand may shake a little bit and
then six months later you're gonna be
going yeah but this is the woman
debt-free this is